well it is fitting that we end with some
uh Yankees highlights because we're
going to begin with a Yankee an
exclusive conversation with baseball
Legend Alex Rodriguez A-Rod dominated
the game for more than two decades he
hit 696 career home runs that's a big
number by the way took home three MVP
awards and won a World Series with the
Yankees back in 2009. now Rodriguez is
on a new Mission and only on CBS
mornings he's revealing he was recently
diagnosed with early stage gum disease
and has since partnered with the Health
Products Company Aura Pharma to help
raise awareness now according to the CDC
nearly half of American adults 30 and
older have some form of gum disease and
it's even more common once you hit 65.
so A-Rod good morning thank you for
being here great to be here now from
where I'm sitting and I'm not a
professional the smile looks good it
seems like it's working so tell me what
what is this gum disease thing well Tony
looks can be deceiving I mean definitely
and I just recently went to see my my
dentist and not thinking anything about
any gum disease and the dentist tells me
the news and then I come to find out
over 65 million Americans have this gum
disease so it's important for all the
viewers watching all Americans all folks
go out there and take care of your teeth
and uh yeah so is it is it mean the gums
are like receding or they're inflamed
and is this in any way tied to all the
stuff baseball players put in their
mouth gum uh you know sunflower seeds
tobacco back in the day that's a great
question and I don't know the exact
technical because it's all recent to me
prevalent in our black and brown
communities especially like my Latino
communities all over the place but you
saw Tony Gwynn years ago past the great
Tony Gwen some of one of my mentors
passed because of a lot of tobacco use
from my understanding so I'm not sure if
tied to that I never did tobacco I did a
lot of sunflower seeds yeah but anyways
viewers at home is always better to be
safe go see your local dentist I
remember when that happened I think we
all remember when that happened when um
Tony Gwynn passed away it was a loss way
too at the age of 54 I believe it was
what was it like for someone who you
looked up to to come out and say tobacco
use has caused me to have what we
understood as mouth cancer and then
passing away from it and you never tie
it together you know to think about just
chewing tobacco leading to cancer
leading to death and a guy like Tony
who's such an amazing guy played hoops
at San Diego State obviously there's a
great picture see you playing baseball
when you see the baseball body he was a
great college basketball he was he would
get that and and a great defender gold
Glover and one of the great great icons
of baseball one of my heroes
I was going to ask you speaking of
baseball let's talk about baseball right
now a lot of new rules in the game
changing things up Pitch clock new
shifts a bigger bases are you in support
of these changes does it make the game a
better game yeah I love the changes and
look I think fans you can't have it both
ways I think Rob Manford and Tony Clark
commissioner and the head of the Union
have done an incredible job this has
been one of the best years in baseball
over the last decade and I'll tell you
why when you look at World Baseball
classic when Japan beat us when Otani
struck out Mike Trout you had over 70
million people watching most of those in
Japan great for the sport and then the
rule change cutting 30 minutes off the
game even my daughters are saying Dad
what's this rule change all about that's
good news when people are talking about
baseball game how do you feel about the
current crop of stars in the game you
mentioned ohtani we got trout Ronald
Acuna Jr I mean the list is endless Tony
you're right and look you play baseball
in college I didn't know that before I
before today
um played with your former teammate Mark
deshara in high school and Mark's a stud
Marcus Smart Guy I was not they used to
walk him to face me I was leaking
confidence you know did a lot to my ego
there by the way we had that in common I
hit fourth he hit third there was
sometimes walk him to face me I love
that but um look I think I'm in love
with the the crop baseball players we
have today I think they're better than
ever before what's exciting about what's
nice they're exciting they're using more
fun bat flips people are excited about
baseball again but this is the best crop
of young players I've seen in a long
time well talking about the Yankees as
we mentioned earlier you know fans are
itching for them to get back in the
world series is Aaron Boone the the
right man for the job I love Aaron Boone
I think Aaron is doing a fantastic job
here's what Tony and I were talking a
little bit offline what's interesting
about New York baseball has never
happened before they had the modern day
George steinburner now and Steve Cohen
who he's got tremendous resources he's
doing a great job with the Mets even
though the Mets are off to a slow start
bets fans would not consider it to be a
great job
spending like a half a billion dollars
give them time you know you gotta judge
Steve Cohen's job if you go to steady
field the job he's doing there what he's
doing in the community he's activated
that great Mets fan base now the Yankees
are always going to be the Yankees but
for the first time ever in over 100
years they're not going to be the
biggest spender in the Big Apple all
right let's talk parenting uh you are a
father who is about to send your oldest
off to college how are you feeling about
that I'm crushed I I'm so excited but
then heartbroken I mean it goes by so
fast for all those parents out there oh
it was his last week Nathan uh I read
her a long letter I broke down crying
like a little baby in front of her yeah
I can't I couldn't help it I have two
Natasha's 18. uh I'll be dropping her
off in August in Ann Arbor and Michigan
and uh boy I'm gonna be if you don't
mind me asking um if you would indulge
us what were some of the things that you
wrote in that letter that you wanted to
say to your daughter because there's a
lot of parents that are in your same
position I am yeah right now yeah that's
a great question I'll tell you how I I
couldn't finish the letter because I
started you know breaking down it was at
my house we had a bunch of my family
over and I basically said you know I'm
supposed to be your role model and here
you are at 18 and you're my role model
wow and uh just so proud of her and
she's going to go do theater they only
accepted 23 students in Michigan
um 11 girls 12 boys and she was one of
the young ladies you know business-wise
you're a lot of people's role model uh
and as we understand it you and your
business partner are one payment away
from owning a majority stake in the
Timberwolves in the NBA you've got it on
layaway right now what's that moment
like it's going to be great um you know
Tony is a dream come true I think every
athlete out there and by the way
athletes have never been smarter better
more talented they don't want to just be
great players they want to be great
business philanthropists they want to
dress well but I think for us as a dream
come true Mark Laurie my partner we own
40 today and the next 60 will be done
hopefully by Year's End you have been a
shouting example of what athletes should
aspire to do after they get done playing
real quick any advice for young guys
young women that are starting their
careers that want to do something
outside of the game that they play yeah
I would just say for athletes actors
anybody who's not in the business
Community number one dream big number
two is all about execution so if you
like basketball you pick Michael Jordan
and be like baseball you pick Aaron
judge go find a Michael Jordan Aaron
judge in the business Community that's
right tie up with them and get a get a
seat you don't have to be driving the
bus just get a nice seat on the bus I
like that thank you for being an example
and rewriting the blueprint of what it
is to be and that smile still working
that's it